un atelier tri des déchets pour
introduire cette rencontre participative
avec la liste citoyenne sans étiquette
agir avec vous pour villepreux la liste
elle s'est d'abord créé au sujet de ce
projet de central park
et puis du coup au fur et à mesure des
réunions on a parlé avec les uns avec
les autres
on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait aussi
d'autres domaines en fait dans la
gouvernance de la ville sur lesquels ont
souhaité intervenir transition
écologique gel des projets
d'urbanisation et notamment le central
park redonner vie au théâtre municipal
sont les grandes lignes du programme on
veut faire une charte du fonctionnement
des team principal sur justement la
transparence des processus de décision
définir des indicateurs rendre compte en
fait aux villes produisent régulièrement
la liste ambitionne également de
s'investir auprès de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
on est entre guillemets les derniers
entrants donc c'est aussi à nous à
trouver notre place au sein de cette
communauté d'agglo et de faire évoluer
la gouvernance pour que les nouvelles
communes qui viennent de rentrer en fait
dans la communauté d'agglo se sentent
intégrés et que nous à l inverse en tant
qu'élu municipal on puisse faire le
relais de la sky auprès des villes
provient prochaines rencontres
participative le 25 janvier pour agir
avec vous.je trois autres listes sont
déjà déclarés sur cette commune celle du
maire sortant stéphane mirambeau de son
ex adjointe sylvie ce 20 août elle est
une dernière menée par jean baptiste à
munich